Philippe Truman jingle man missing in
action were so full podcast welcome to
the were so full podcast with rodrigo
torres yemen it also has a young man
podcast and right here Felipe Esparza
and managed to just get to business bro
since it's been two weeks I'm gonna get
to it man this weekend I'll get stirred
to the six of you in Oxnard California
and every live Oxnard next week August
11 to the 13 Memphis Tennessee at chocos
comedy house you know chuckles comedy
house in Memphis Tennessee if you live
within I don't care man if you want to
drive eight hours to the show from where
we're at I'm a girl with free tickets
all right i'ma hook it was passage if
you live it in I don't care how far you
live on this come to this show man calm
down anyway so come on man I know
there's some message the Tennessee you
know man somebody that I pick up those
fruits over there all right
August 18 Milwaukee Wisconsin AB cutter
what home a casino Potawatomi casino the
Northern Lights theater ooh
other nights one light two shows I'll be
there who became with Adam Murray and
Rodrigo Torres that's right well Judith
I will be there we're gonna do it up no
walkies best I don't know maybe for the
picking up a big separate cheese over
there in a beer dog yeah hell yeah [ __ ]
yeah we'll do Lucky's best and a slice
some coleslaw August 24 through 27 Brea
improv these shows will sell out before
the we start so hurry and get your
tickets I remember the first time I was
performing their blood giveaway so many
free tickets people are buying tickets
that we couldn't give the ticket away
for free man I lost a lot of fans but so
people I used to get in for free so
chances out there were never gonna be
paying fans check out Philippians
world.com slash tour for our show dates
the rest of the year also a plug for all
things comedy Fred pas virzi he's
shooting his first special and
it's a first special that will be
produced by audience comedy so come out
and support what our things comedy is
doing to help comedians Sunday August
13th at the tari or Tarrytown Music Hall
in Tarrytown New Jersey New York
tari town New York Tarrytown New York
you know whatever except Tarrytown New
York if you want to go pawn virzi is
doing a special for special guest
appearance by bill burr and Pete
Davidson huh it should be the other way
around
anyways get your tickets at Palmer z.com
for the 9:30 p.m. show before they sell
out
actually um no jokes aside bill burr
it's actually pushing this show very
much because it's the first special done
here at our things comedy hopefully
they'll do more special was Vigo yeah
but in a little envelope to El Masri go
hook us up today to do another producing
[ __ ] yeah just shoutouts to other people
who gave us an iTunes review man we're
gonna read these oh my god so I'm up
what am I taking a reading classic test
it's not dark enough for me to see this
Rodrigo has a liberal here we go this
one is a low by refund my money Wow
Rodrigo and Felipe make an hour fly by
at work thank you for making me laugh
and making me forget that I'm at a
corporate job listening to you guys talk
about comedy real-life situations and
achieving your goals it really motivates
me and helps me get through my job so
once I clock out I don't go home and
watch TV I focus on my music and other
things that will get me closer to my
goal if you read this far man thank you
the both of you hey Joseph this one's
from [ __ ] to Mendez
this guy says this pastas podcast has a
last guarantee yeah man and this one's
from hilarious five stars by miss London
four to four I just started listening to
this podcast about two weeks ago and
it's definitely one of my favorites so
far it's funny entertaining and honest
i tota madre five stars by l pintado you
know what make a big laptop this is one
of the best and funniest podcast
available yeah man keeping it real five
stars by necromancer 95 I started
listening this year after Philippe came
to the Arlington improv this podcast
gets me through my workday and I applaud
your courage and sharing your struggles
naturally there are a lot of funny
moments but you guys always keep it real
listening has also inspired me to
transition towards becoming vegan and I
look forward to hearing about more
eating spots as you continue with your
travels big love to you in both of you
phenomenal podcast phenomenal podcast
five stars by land girl and OH
Regis I absolutely love your podcasts
you are hilarious getting me through the
day every Friday it's what I look
forward to not to be a stalker like but
you know I just monger the Porter Ranch
you're going to have the area I live in
in Winnetka if you want to check out the
valley roll low rider scene let me know
Langer languor s Langer Jess on IG love
you guys and this one awesome pot boom
that's it ready extremely entertaining
and there you go those are the reviews
wow man they got I said another stalker
let me tell you man let me tell you man
you could keep it you can keep it like
like you could do a video a periscope
without putting we're location
[ __ ] recognize the screen a car
I know you're a bro you're a 1634
Eastern speed era cool I know go through
three goddamn repair in an alley they
won't find you matters there's a way to
fireman don't find out like like if
you're standing there and a plane passes
by they'll find out what plane if it
southwards or find out what flying by
website number where's planner at that
moment don't find out your location
longitude and latitude bro John Wayne
Airport right there that's what brought
oh give the rest in no more brush you
have you [ __ ] anybody at the
directions in 2015 there's a [ __ ]
killer broke some stuff [ __ ] you need
directions for Google that's it done
just strangle you man yeah man once a
once I give somebody direction in the
end how to get there do you you're in
comfort over my house
there's a preneur too old to go to my
house I said if you allows it too loud
you too bro
your muscles gonna fall my house get
hurt clock that sue me now bugs if I
give it a direct address and know I'll
be there in five minutes you could come
over man
I don't want to anybody calls me like
champ Oh bro hey bro what boss you gotta
catch there you ain't coming buses don't
come over here you ain't coming brother
for [ __ ] up with ankle playing
basketball
are you serious yeah bro so he's not a
comedy again I was never in any way
we went away for a while I was in
corporates Christi Texas with um with
[ __ ] Toby Higgs bro yeah man we
talked about bender a while hell but we
talked about it real quick on the phone
it's a really racial towards them oh my
god dude you know Chris Doering man so
I'm blazing right on his patio right so
this model weed so right away they go to
Toby hey room for a black he's knocking
it was so you gotta tell your friend to
stop smoking so my friend not even over
there who wears yet he the water burger
why we know the smoke here it's coming
from there god damn say well you know
where they be man so [ __ ] it a name be
the blame and then what happens know why
I was able to get a warning bro I wanted
to warm them too bro but how shitty
hotel was is it to see one block no oh
god I hope y'all got worse
I bet dude oh man we're against your
brother we gotta warn your own friends
whatever you did we get booked in Corpus
Christi
do not stay at the corporates I thought
at the Bayfront hotel oh my god oh my
god about never confident the open 24
hours and other employees are a mess
everyone had this week irzu mad bro oh
so reviewing him the review say that
hotel you were staying in just from a
week before I was staying this we
checked in we got an early check-in and
man they said that we saw a big yellow
stain on the bed somebody have a baby or
we asked for a different room and they
gave her a different room man he said
there was like I'm the water room smell
like muggy like mildew man it was bad
bro there were people watching her
clothes in the pool
ah
it was bad boo people are living their
big ass bad hobby luna bro we got
married it no well yeah I had a close-up
on my lucky go turn on his um his a blow
dryer three roaches came off and oh the
rose gone broke everything the
thermostat had roaches a phone had
roaches a TV had rode to the dog and
didn't even come out the first day doll
you took him to like the third day to
get confident stuff for this fool in
front gate what's your television a
roach camera screen bring us our flag
bro on a flat screen yeah no I wasn't
even a fight the box ones full and on
the microwave the little of the little
clock had roaches in their dogs
discussion and they may have five
brothers they were paisa they're Texas
right little kilo Spanish but really I
thought they were working they were
working there they were working at the
hotel that do some kind of construction
and those fools made a hallway a kitchen
oh dude what they had that [ __ ] all
that set up the little George Foreman
grill a little it's cooling in the
hallway Holloway bro with the little
hibachi grills and share with the little
propane tank attached to it I love
Fiesta Hall yeah man you know let's get
a man when you see a one employee
walking around with a cup of noodles bro
is not even shrimp oh my god vegetable
flavor
yeah man saw it was [ __ ] hot how did
the last time hi it was Cristobal any
rain and it was to 108 you humor bro you
and they Toby hates you know that we're
gonna come out but that's what I got but
you'd only black to that weekend bro
thats everywhere everywhere bro
he was an anima animal oh the crime rate
window with him walking around
that's real estate went down German it
was bad and then I'm the claw for
shout-out to joint venture sandwiches if
you ever go to Corpus Christi be sure to
go to joint venture they're not
promoting or her nothing about promoting
them because they gave me a 600 thing or
they gave me a nice bong bro it was like
it's like a little it's like a little um
spaceship with a little alien next time
I'll do George Perez stories or bring it
over oh hell yeah bro man I don't know
man anyways man blood George Perez
look right here and I guess you know
what's up my boy over here you know
waiting no intro but yeah bad I didn't
know I mean I didn't know like you guys
were going on I wasn't introduce you
right now yeah I know people you're here
bro
did I acknowledge you you got me over
here more has been the camera but no I
know what a name wrong he'd want to be
in a film you know I mean where was
there but you're against not a host oh
right there
I don't know where the camera is
probably huh you got the mic the
engineer over here Adam amen
joint venture by the way the ones they
wanted to open up a smoke shop you know
but you know hard cuz you know very
conservative corporate Christy brought a
little town so you know they were the
rather you open up ten churches before
you open up a smoke shop so Alan just
for fun a way to get away with it he
opened up us a sandwich shop first okay
so it's a sandwich shop and a smoke shop
so it's together and other sandwiches
have a marijuana names like the laser oh
yeah
it's like a [ __ ] sandwich you know
although the tuna the week sandwich is
like the vegan one or whatever the
stress whatever but the Reggie so he got
away with opening up a a bong shop with
a sandwich shop so on one side it's a
bunch of [ __ ] sandwiches but on the
other side smoke shop and that way
nobody gets there and they make sure to
sandwich is a real delicious because the
Sun will suck the people that we say
well actually man he just took moksha we
should eat sandwiches but actually it
was a good sandwich bar so shout out to
the guy the first time I was there then
forgive me a [ __ ] Debbie rig and now
he gave me a bong broad and looked at in
a real nice one and I've smoked a lot of
shitty bongs and then we show him a good
one is different huh
tell the difference does ya the smoke
you mean good and wide broom a white
smoke perfect let that Brown smoke I'm
used to okay what are you smoking Dyke
so who could shout out to Corpus Christi
Texas my first night there man
my hotel room was filled with [ __ ]
white teenage kids though wouldn't have
a game or something you know what they
were doing that farm [ __ ] you did when
you were a kid our age
agriculture agriculture Future Farmers
of America the people in Omaha go real
future farmers they look at poker future
farmer bro it was soda wear suspenders
bro no real white people black
Cornhuskers real white people bro for
you for the polite real like when a 10th
birthday they give the full rifle kind
of my people as they go buy guns and a
family together remember their yeah man
so the food was straight up you know
like Christian white you know
conservative because I remember like the
world we're outside smoking in [ __ ] this
girl said gosh y'all y'all should stop
that smoking damn you know about to say
y'all should shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] so
you know I don't want y'all also gonna
be here for another [ __ ] three days
y'all were going to be here for only one
more night so as soon as uh they said
that I just continued to smoke turn it
off when inside my room and then like
they started smoking cigarettes
ah dude that's what they should stop
yeah man dumb ass [ __ ] those because
Tommy Hayes probably for god damn dog
like a snow shadow of the death oh my
god bro they I come with you at that
shitty hotel you a stay in they charge
for parking every night yeah pull right
there on that social for the target bro
bro they're gonna watch it nobody some
people probably sleep in the car zone
that's why the word hotel ever bro so
anyway so we're looking at the mesquite
comedy club they're gonna open up a new
comedy club they really look at a closer
one the rain bro man how about filling
up these clothes furs then open up a new
one we get that going please it's not
gonna be the same venue then yeah bro
quarter skating down downtown is rotting
away bro
for your brother yes let us build some
real real expensive loft [ __ ]
are empty because too expensive to live
with at that walk-in muffle the walk-in
yeah yeah so now I found out that we're
gonna let downtown right away you know
let it decay and then with people with
money show up buy it and then rebuilt
but right now no damn hope what they're
doing to Detroit okay
[ __ ] yeah there's nothing in downtown
brother you know you know the the
downtown is shitty bro when are they
have with a barbershop and it's a
two-parter bro a bit shitty ass [ __ ]
store where you could to buy copper
noodle that one organic place but - is
expensive bro that should scare tourists
away talking about where the snow cones
do they have those responses - I was
terrible at Selena statue bro there's no
hustle bro there's no horse - and
corporates Christine nobody they want to
make money bro [ __ ] that
like I know brought all the crackhead
you know like that's a real statue just
nobody there selling Selena's shirts I
want [ __ ]
George would you be telling shirt there
I be shining like this is the [ __ ]
knife that stabbed her publisher
research away free let off a server
Selena will host a liberal yes the
bangbang yeah bro no hustle there I
guess the dad has it all locked down I
bet it is nothing right there bro I
don't say leader look alike right
they're both taking photo with people I
worked out
someone who look like the killer
standing right there bro I'm gonna draw
now with a gun bro and Salinas Yuri bro
then that lady just died there's nobody
there bro
making money bro his body just a statue
by it's out bro those pickle juice my
spouse all [ __ ] yeah bro stood man we
went withdrawal we went to the [ __ ] I
was possible and I'm they said that up
this how you know man this [ __ ] buy
sell order a powerful powerful doctor
forget the party with a bro
yeah no flavor no [ __ ] flavor just
[ __ ] hot starts of Texas for you and
then his hillbilly girlfriend bro she
ordered a [ __ ] um first of all she
brought her checkbook now so she's
[ __ ] down she were are gonna follow
full of pickle juice bro ah girls pickle
juice bro and she call it a white beyond
equal that's full of trailer-trash bro
that means your house have an alarm like
this [ __ ] drinks Coors Light I don't
what's wrong - Marlene bro her kids have
silver teeth bro trailer trash trailer
trash balance out the trailer trash
white footage
reberty now riverside so hardcore dude
to the colorful Orange County yeah but
they're more like recovering drug
addicts all right they all hang out by
the by the [ __ ] you never been they all
hang out with the brother train station
but waiting is shot Sydney should have
homeless guy over there they killed one
the cops know in Fullerton right yeah
yeah they choked them out right there on
downtown Fullerton I remember we should
do comedy at church right there yeah
yeah that's where they got him what was
always better than broom they weren't
around there was a little protest for
that food or mother she was cracking for
that foot for a while right yeah well
they let the cops go right well no they
found out they found out he was guilty
really got him yeah okay cuz I thought
they let to those go because one of them
already had history of it the one the
one cop that was missing and I yeah boy
it was like the movie gridlock like the
bum that they beat up he used to be
somebody remember like how like in a
movie two parking Belushi they killed a
bum it was Harrison Ford right yeah this
guy was somebody that just had a drug
problem and something like paranoid
schizophrenia follows a good cop right I
think something another dad tried to run
for a mayor of Fullerton after that
yeah that's an inside job right there
they got some mad money for him if the
dad comes out of nowhere after the kid
gets killed I bricks that Buzzard up
roll well that's a bit what right after
I go though when I catch the train it's
right there by the sidewalk when I cut
out when I cut the train to go to Brea I
cut the train in downtown LA and then I
got off by the train station right there
man man that's not a good spot to hit a
bowl what I supposed to ask you for a
hit dog these cops loop on your ass
Tomer want to etiquette tonight sure
pull and F where's fungus [ __ ] up
plus to let him out let me blow it on
you you really ask me can I have it man
transient specialist on my last night
bro I had an audition right and I was
waiting for the buzzer away for a bus
ticket it kind of way for uber a list as
how this [ __ ] [ __ ] bro who looks
like my eggs bro what a little bro
hahaha everybody for brows sorry I never
saw her talking you're hardcore
sir-sir stated right bingo she goes she
just doing her feet free were all boxes
$30 and black right it's just like you
asked any questions bro like um you know
what time it is and I say yeah it's like
444 you know what time we get dark in
here delay like [ __ ] you don't know how
long you been awake so far telling her
the circus dog when you close your eyes
[ __ ]
she look like she been up for five days
right so and just came to our lady
excited a party hard the [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro you know and then she telling me man
I wish I had your hair you hear so
awesome it's so gorgeous
I'll tell me she wanted to touch it
though no bro no bro that [ __ ] was in
shade too bro said a body like [ __ ]
scruncho rip this [ __ ] will choke a
[ __ ] out for a pipe right there and
right there and I'm West Hollywood and
respond like um that corner is money bro
it's money bro because by doing that
corner like if you may have a minute
while I was telling chilling over there
right by a tree doing nothing and I
slept over there dummy they were making
they were filming a movie right I know
on the street poinsettia whatever did
they shut down their [ __ ] whole
neighborhood to shoot the film there
that's expensive right there was
Hollywood right anybody knows how to
make a movie bro they [ __ ] shut it
down they had a cop there fool they had
a [ __ ] catering truck catering people
food the whole field was being fed was
[ __ ] in an outro and they had an in
and out lunch truck
feeding all the actors so this was know
million dollar production
meanwhile we have [ __ ] Donald ed over
here asking what time does the Sun come
out whatever the Sun leave to go back to
fully people's I'm a [ __ ] man we've
been away for it to get dark to talk
bully [ __ ]
yeah such a dick I don't know man who
you'd be really desperate house you ever
do a dirty [ __ ] that dirty go down on
you
now really a bro couple of bad clones
dog share a razor dog house in rehab
they're doing this [ __ ] do name
alejandro
- like a what a modern full crackhead
from a little village from the projects
and we're talking about Road stories
that we were telling stories that we're
ensuring the meetings right
the real ones and it's the real ones
because if we're told me that he would
let gay dude suck his dick bro god damn
for like $20 okay why bro because I want
to get high yeah but but but but you let
him yeah bro what they do nam and
director jerky nostril so that's was
blowing you and jerking off gross dogs
because not like a bad summer done I no
matter the summer of 89 but that's all
freak [ __ ] though like [ __ ] with
transvestites and all that [ __ ] though
right I mean I don't know I'm just
saying I don't know man normal right and
I wasn't sound like a stories were too
believable bro like why would a man pay
another man to blow him and he should be
the way around like a man should be
asking doubtful for $20 hey boys 20
bucks blow me I don't know I don't think
the other way around
what do you think I don't know wearing a
wig or something it's it's the doggy I
remember I read a book I'm okay I had to
be a Latin King in prison and he was
saying that like gay guys will pull over
to the young bum kids and tell him hey
let me bone you or suck my dick I'll
give you money and that's how they pimp
themselves off without full from The
Ramones used to [ __ ] pimp is a self
out like that here alone but he was a
high toilet to talk about morning he's
dead now but he was a hot dog I know man
I I think Tom I never got that that
close you know like to way a man get
freaky and [ __ ] with another phone the
closer was an aspirin bro oh it's
somebody trying to get all up onions are
full an aspect of our places brother
Aspen with that comedian we had on a
show here the career one
pika Oh Kevin Shea Kevin Shea we got
invited with by David Brenner a big-time
Femina he told financial get a little
shoulder and
and dude during my drunken days you
remember and you know man all on a
mission from God
bro to explore some kind of team
hardcore drugs in Aspen so right away
bro a bicycie min is on where'd you find
that he just came in bro he came in
under snow he was an angel he works he
was the reverse their brother Boris like
the kitchen club that puts that night to
me so we're talking and [ __ ] aaaa and
then I'm Kevin Shea was talking in the
blonde chick his lady whatever they're
talking with another he I start talking
to him
so bring this by side to a conversation
right whatever that I have to bring you
know where to get some blow come on I'm
bossy I'll go I'll leave yeah let me
come on hey
my stylish is horrible but I know how to
talk to the help I know how to talk to
buy stuff bro like nobody's business but
I'll [ __ ] your Spanish lawyer or LeTip
bro give me an English one bro simple
era you know I don't need his help
Olivia I'm a new path website describes
me to service well ever male true mundo
cob road you know all pretty much you
know I'm selling myself as a cokehead to
this guy she was walking home but
presume so me and his [ __ ] Oaxacan
[ __ ] right we went to the
bathroom and a foot takes out a [ __ ]
bump so I went home I did it right hook
hook sinker right I'm gonna get you the
[ __ ] yeah but I did it was tight so I
told him that I'm walking more dog what
the [ __ ] so so we're like last call and
[ __ ] so before last call brother or
another beers and put it in my jacket to
take him with me you know so I have like
last cars they give me seven six beers
broke so I [ __ ] start hiding on bro
don't open them so I don't [ __ ] it a
higher my jacket bro I don't know where
to find liquor storage bucket ask my bro
so I'm already a beer I can never be sad
I got a flight at 7 in the morning
no I
ten cement so for all the fools are
walking and Kevin Shea leaves with his
chick we're staying in the same little
condo in Aspen it was like a dam it was
a breakfast or something but it was not
really like a it was what no really like
cashier computer it was one of those bed
and breakfast then in breakfast places
so I go to my room bro and I took the
[ __ ] by side with me bro thing that
really interested way only so we taught
you those beers they I start doing my
act for him you know like all of us in
school I don't know brother entertained
this guy a little ticks so the bindles
therefore we're doing the blowpro and
then like um the foot holding out dog
how'd you know dick I said I realized
it's a holding out bro so for I took a
$100 and say bro listen man I want you
to eat that were partying for free dog
so here's $100 man for you just taking
here for another hour
is he alright so I'm [ __ ] ripped I
shouldn't have booked him half you get
the other half when the hours over
[ __ ] keep bringing that powder
[ __ ]
so we're partying bro stuff we start
getting closer
no I'll give them the other half later
I'm brought old man you know man keep
bringing that dope so we're a blended or
alcohol right so I told that fool he was
gonna leave there's no more alcohol so I
put a hold on I call up the front
there's a man getting alcohol there for
that is that for the gas you know so why
we have a refrigerator help yourself
fool what's the refrigerator I got a
bottle of wine dropped it I [ __ ] broke
[ __ ] wine everywhere in that kitchen
that's so [ __ ] dude you know me dog I
didn't clean it and actually shed you
left it there does so I got two more two
more bottles of wine upon a bottle of
vodka so it went up there bro there's no
juice but those oranges in the room so
doing vodka and orange juice can capture
ugh so
can a other alcohols their dinner why
and you know this was not getting closer
to me bro like targeting closer so he
asked me how come that chikna here it's
a what shake [ __ ]
now whether that attack was a chi know
the blonde way that were the Asian food
for the hair feels awful de'medici
covered I'm all you got
this foo he he thought I was gay too bro
hey I'm just gonna lucky [ __ ]
whoever has a beer bro can get uglier so
I put I was security tip dominica
operator for nothing wait whoa
signior easily I'll only put it on
Fernanda Burnham Gugu la mochila soul so
i look at a lo actors want to be closing
him up okay i gay dog so um that fool
left up damn dude I'm sorry I'll check a
[ __ ] him to know libro I was chasing
that fool another was another half
hundred Josue beneath house where I was
yelling bro in the snow bro he left it
was like a bad Fargo scene going back to
heaven time just ran full and then I
chased him and I realized bro I was in
my pajamas but not with this underwear
socks I don't know how to I forgot to a
pajama but dude I Ramos time has passed
by you know you're doing coke bro and
drinking you don't know timewise you
know it could have been six hours but
you think in one hour and goes I
realized all about myself in a snow so I
just [ __ ] started running back to the
hotel room and then went back to the
kitchen and got another bottle of wine
they were a bachelor room started
partying and realized his wine and a
floor look [ __ ] danger everywhere
dude I got up talking six to the morning
flight leaves at 10 I got time for put
on my whatever clothes I had watching a
liquor store but a six a 12-pack I can
[ __ ] it no more drugs I'm sad I can't
sleep but I won't get [ __ ] up so I'm
feeling Foster Foster
after that I go okay hour left so I
caught a cab if we wouldn't go all the
way to my hotel broker those too much
snow so he waited down there not for
[ __ ] jet it got to the car he gave it
to the hotel gave it to the [ __ ]
Airport I barely made it a CPAP Bob goes
there was up he goes I barely made it
full but time I made it home they wanted
my check back could our damages bro how
the room and damages at the one time he
said all right Pat ho next time white
whiny reksai white white yeah that's why
I cost them like a trip 200 dollars in
damages all I want to know man who
decides how much money was causing
damages they go there looker stood I was
partying at I'll be reporting I was
hanging out with Isaac bro we were
jumping in the beds will jump from bed
to bed and threw a pillow I hear me to a
pillow at me to a pillow at him he dug
in [ __ ] hit a [ __ ] I'm Hard Rock
Cafe painted a Bob Dylan I got like a
picture of Bob Dylan a framed photo
falls that's just three hundred fifty
five dollars and you I know a frame guy
yeah all you need is a glass writer the
frame broke too yeah [ __ ] I just let
me keep the diddling keep int five Tim
bro Lisa called them he had a particular
the charge oh really
let's go oh they did to get out yeah
Matt they always charge X to Assiut food
war so for your code that me let that
now I've seen people cause damage though
I never saw the response I was over and
this was the worser food our guest today
comes all the way from Orange County
from Santana Lawrence from or as I said
man you know I'm an actual gang is
hanging anyway I met this comedian man
actually met when I was on Google on
yahoo messenger I took a home messenger
some crazy chick bro that you to work at
Hot Tamales and I'm she was like a host
at um some show mamma mias in Culver
City or somewhere she's always trying to
get me to do comedy showed over there
but I never did I'm Benny man I did and
some other [ __ ] man
I didn't fall for that trap you know I
don't want to you know I don't want to
talk to a person and then everyone want
me to do a show
[ __ ] that waste so losing lose my number
i'ma lose yours right now so we took
child okay she was cool then she told me
there's this comedian I Casa latina that
hosted sometimes he's like a cholo
he's finally right and then I'm I found
out it was his name she's all Jorge
Perez and as they all heard of the guy
man yeah man I heard of that pool so I
looked him up bro googled him
so to make sure I knew him stop lying
[ __ ] right cause you want to keep the
conversation going so I go to him and
then I got a picture of bomb another
rain Pryor or Richard Pryor wife it was
like a special event show and had George
Perez with an air photo with them as the
DJ bjg Perez
TJ unit yell DJ name before no okay then
it was a misprint seconds Corey Holcomb
was at that thing yeah yeah yeah and
then they all right moving up in the
world haven't even met Richard Pryor
wife but I've met Ronnie danger feels
like hey hey hey hey man so I'm [ __ ]
out I started knowing more about them
when um when Chappell started hanging
around with us big yeah bro I let that
fool host and it's like it took over bro
you flatter me bro what happened bro I
was hosted by this [ __ ] showed up bro
I let him host one week and then the
next week didn't want me no more bro Wow
like I was chapo how did you let him
prove it not even your groom
hahaha how you let him host yeah bro
while I stay with a new bro they told
you to leave maybe did they tell you
so anyways Gosselaar I stopped going to
Casa latina BAM brokers I don't know it
was changing you know why I was getting
work other places now in plus they were
not pay me no more
now every time I showed up to a casa
latina and absorb and I saw fly wearing
a suit nobody's gonna get paid
through the food - with a brown suit
knocking the brown jacket bro it's over
his old house it was over a broom and
then then I definitely stopped going
there because the devil was performing
one night and they were filming a
special for him and then they said you
got ready for the biggest comedian ever
and I got up and I said oh man I hope
[ __ ] get regressing that here and they
had to cut bro
so after that I was done at that place
and but the story - homie that guy Edgar
and he choked me up and DJ Lanza no
neighbors or whatever name was further
extras extra and then [ __ ] [ __ ]
that crazy I fool oh yeah yeah being a
fool like yo the God who lives down the
street I know a guy that knows a guy i
lured a 13 that his name is um Stevie
Steven and he grew up in that area by
Casa latina
he said there's something to go there he
knows me up he lives down that he lives
on Garvey in a trailer park right there
he was outside one day tomorrow he got
crazy dogs but I couldn't stop at leave
that fool you still there he was not
[ __ ] by you like slow no slash slow
he was slow but therefore memorized the
devil's jokes it was hilarious Teddy
next to him what a fight I was a Buddha
that's what the hallway walking around
like a devil it's a good me I was gonna
dress up that fluid ever one day that
would have been hilarious so one night I
forgot where we bad bro we were a
customer so no I we were at a fly had
that room in Long Beach Northern Lights
Northern Lights it was like on top of
the Cuban bar or something through we're
at the body with Joey Diaz was there
that's right [ __ ] yeah hello
would it fill up my check all night yeah
follow him to the [ __ ] ATM dude that
room I remember the first night I was
there armed those a black fool I know
like this crazy white chick bro like
them too
rayji from Long Beach from the east side
probably and some other chicks there
hanging around and there are in a group
for this [ __ ] Tuesday night Tuesday
night show right I was a to [ __ ] 8
p.m. 9 p.m. on the black dude and that
che get kicked out bro
for what that she was blowing him right
there bro tight there's not even a big
club scene bro it was even [ __ ]
packed it made there get a room
go to the [ __ ] car farmer the
security that was gonna come on y'all
it's Tuesday night y'all get some y'all
get out of here man they just think that
[ __ ] on the way out I don't know what I
was done now but yeah they kicked out
bro Dampier so um pinky in it I don't
know I I met you um I went to a fly's
house to get a lo sack skipped over the
baby and then I so that's how George
Perez and Edwin oh yeah named Adam bro
and it was like eat 9 o'clock and I said
[ __ ] this this was gonna click and play
Madden and slow weed too late almost a
year too and I still do - like - bro the
pad off rampart yeah man
though I was living on you would like
the people under the stairs were there
they had little autistic kid yeah I had
a crazy kid brought out something he'll
run inside a room and grab other
controllers naked oh [ __ ] I don't know
dungeon huh
that yeah it was it was crate he would
jump up member he would jump in the
windows ya know what can we ask we ask
Lyle who went up enough between apply
between yuck milk and this fool he said
therefore cuz he has strong yeah he said
out there for you remember yeah [ __ ]
string
yeah so I said he's bringing the
groceries one time and he was holding
him he wouldn't let him go to fly so I
was like dog he killed on to that [ __ ]
wasn't a little kid good at video games
I don't know what are you talking up
dude just [ __ ] [ __ ] up dog he will
let him in the house do ya I guess we're
alone up lighthouse yeah that girl
upstairs no Claire move right yeah he
moved
I remember that spot Mel was a good spot
man I remember the vault
oh yeah I remember the first time like I
really got to talk to you
dog I don't know you remember this but
like I must have been like a year and a
half and I was like yeah year and a half
two years in and you were their only
fool doing Ross jokes back then no one
was doing Ross joke because nobody
shopped there yes you really did and
then we're at mixed nuts though you
never mixed mixed nuts yeah yeah that's
when I first I seen you go out there
with a [ __ ] up Padre shirt and you
said this joke about and I was like what
the [ __ ] and then pulling it up what's
up you got weed a will go with me I went
outside and there was a Sava Dorian
waitress there and yeah that was
something that was like after that I
don't know
that was weird remember that night bro
we went outside and there was a couple
of like I know the another there was no
salad or gangster they were outside and
wondering sailor Hill had a rap and it
was a chaplain had a rap battle him bro
oh this is a wild coyote and I forgot
our scare bro
that would like just battle him but with
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] around you ride
all day bro till I get down in studios
oh my god
then I told you oh yeah then I came in
one time bro on a girl to one bro I came
in with a redneck fool bro some trailer
trash pool and and Josh woody part still
insisting so friend you were there hit
between the show and I don't think it
with my room anymore
and I'm used and I told you bro that's
how you know you're funny bro when your
friend start being your friend and I
said and then little by little bro ex
can't bro we were except yeah I told you
that well you're not honey bro you're
funny man but let nobody bring you down
bro because the bigger tighter keep you
down now you can't go to that room
you're not ready but you're ready now
man [ __ ] all that [ __ ] and then yeah
maybe taking a brewing in numb they numb
you were under your mama hugging your
mama by the way if you will go watch out
your mama
MTV your mama it was a show with that
guy I'm Wilmer Valderrama oh my god bro
you winner you and your mama burn you
want the best your mama was [ __ ] at
the [ __ ] dough is not film bro when you
going on with you you're going after
that blackboard I remember a DeLand who
homeboys house yeah I did it all yeah
here we go yeah I forgot about that uh
yeah cuz I remember it was in apartments
and they had like a little crowd out
yeah she had the Volvo - I had to evolve
over me shuffle showed up bro
shuffle showed up just to cheerlead
again here at villains house the old
Ripper pole in there and everything yeah
yeah well I guess um
Manny Maldonado had an agent back in I
don't know if he does still not if he
did it doesn't but were the Paterson I
don't know and then uh I guess they hit
him up asking do you know anybody that's
good at your mama jokes and he was like
now that's not my game but he gave them
my info not cool so then uh you know I
[ __ ] told punk ass Dylan I'll a dog
I'm gonna make it a I need a ride i I
don't have a car so this fool took me
down there he had like a little studio
and it's weird because I walked in the
office and there was like just normal
people and then he made me battle those
people after that Wilmer put me on you
better a chick - huh yeah I battled that
[ __ ] out bro yeah but you know what's
crazy that's Jimmy Kimmel's nice it was
yeah i v-i
her remember the grandpa was on the show
if you look at the episode yeah the
grandpa was on the show damn I know that
was it oh the best joke you heard on
your mama somebody the best one I heard
I don't know man it was a long time ago
George - this bad ass fool broke it down
for you smile a knee surgery yeah or I
don't know one of my favorites that I
said that I said on there was a your
soul your muscle fat that Jesus can't
even lift her spirits like I don't know
it hits everything right there
I don't know but it's weird dog because
a season with it it was three seasons
they did they did the best of our LA did
then went to New York then they went to
Miami how many people tell you a rich
after that [ __ ] cause you were the first
one ah
you are like a dog let's go to less
nosfy least I'll give you free
McDonald's right now
but uh yeah dog I mean I only got like
what five thousand and they give you a
thousand - ooh yeah that's cool yeah but
[ __ ] it was crazy because then I got
locked up and that's what we started
kicking at the mostess after I got out
remember I bailed out yeah like a lot of
people don't know this dog but Felipe's
birthday was the last time I was out
remember you had a we had the sunset
room yes those are room yeah you're like
a dog get some of this cake it might be
the last time
hello you locked up word I did three
years damn yeah yeah you know what about
bad stuff you had fans in there though
it was weird like I was like [ __ ] it
cuz like don't get me wrong dawg
I never thought you were like cholo as
like they gave you love in there I was
there like your comedian or sounds like
yeah they and they're like you know who
Batman is
I was like who the [ __ ] is Batman
they're like deepest bars along oh you
don't Felipe than that yeah they're
doing your old jokes daughter like he
has a joke about a spam key oh I was
still [ __ ] open mic and dog that is
ah what'd I do wrong with a minute man
go to mixtape right there yeah I started
like a mixtape babe we're gonna get cut
off Hadar you don't hear my real homie
the guy from The Breakfast Club and if
he was funnier like there were the
breakfast of the bully fool at you da
like he clowned everybody woman :
yeah he had Nelson yeah he clowns
everybody huh detention that's Felipe
dog like you should know super he is his
fellow noble trust us yeah hunter [ __ ]
ah you have that swagger balls about
absolutely
oh I remember my I had a roommate and
that food told me that he was working as
a PR in a show and Judge Nelson came out
of a room screaming rule yeah what
happened screaming screaming bro like I
was all about a dog on a good one
out there's a real good one oh damn yeah
that happens to a lot of those fools so
um when you were locked up you're like
duh because somebody press charges on
you yeah dog oh oh oh stay right leg
yeah Oh fight you got a you got a memory
I've changed remember when you first met
me I was more like size 46 pants still
all cholo still active nothing fit huh
yeah it's a weird a I know bro you
autoload out bro it says shirt to show a
knives you sure you hold me then [ __ ]
like it's funny when you started doing
stand-up comedy I remember when I start
doing stand-up comedy
so that first I don't know how to how to
go or how to approach it so I will take
home eat with me right and man those
would be shell-shocked at places I took
them to Brooklyn so used to be used to
places where people gonna start [ __ ]
with them then I used to go to a play
where nobody's gonna start [ __ ] with
them yeah there's more paranoid like
with your friends I know your friend
bitters at the comedy shows in the
beginning and they're like sitting down
brunette little kids bro well qual proof
well-behaved yeah doc you know how it is
when you're a homie if you're gonna act
out you're gonna get [ __ ] up it don't
last too long even have to fight the
bouncer but that's how it is you know do
you start doing those shows on Tapatio
tuesdays now yeah I did compactor
Tuesdays I kind of big you that you're
doing tequila tequila Street blow with a
misspelled cue
I remember you loved that banner Lord oh
you're like everybody sees it when I
walk in dog I still have it
ha ha so man footprint was one of the
first foods to pack on a show bro at the
brand proper way improper Wednesday's
right yeah hell's a long time ago first
I used to have south-of-the-border
Saturdays at Irvine but like I don't
know a dog Irvine was weird to me
because even the manager is like a when
your shows are here they have the cops
kicker right there to watch all the fans
go ah how's your brother's money broom
yeah that there's too much Santana
tattoos on their head doctor
when you were locked up man were you
doing stand-up in there I mean you're
just calm I always tell people man right
now brother operator please to come home
freedom bro a little real booty call ha
ha now Dawg like you were the only fool
that wrote me you and Edwin dog and I
remember your letter cuz it was like a
doc perfume bro
yeah Rodrigo what's it like this fool
must have been [ __ ] on a good one I
was a lot of me because it was like old
vintage like paper it had like the gold
lying on the side and he wrote cool man
and Roy yeah dog but I remember calling
you cuz I had a cell phone but yeah dog
I used to do comedy in prison you know
the CIO's uh the Showtime special just
came out I was on by [ __ ] comedy slam
yeah so I'm in there and it's out and
the seals are all rasa most of the most
of the prisoner cops are rasa and they
were like dog I just seen you on TV so
they got together and they were like hey
we're gonna have this full do comedy in
the dorms because first I had to do it
for the cops
but then the home is like you ain't
doing [ __ ] for them dog and I was like I
can't do it and they're like whoa whoa
all the inmates have to be there so I
used to go dorm the dorm dog and
everybody would like pay with like a
soup like an apple open Sally yeah yeah
look ya know but it wasn't cell living
at that time we were living in like Old
Navy bunkers so at modules or was yeah
it was called the barracks dorms okay
and it's weird ugh because when a riot
kicks off in there it's a hundred people
just ah it's funny one time there was an
earthquake and I was locked up and
everybody thought I was a riot dawg it
was [ __ ] funny you were there that
riot they showing them on [ __ ] the
History Channel the big-ass one no I
wasn't there I was next door to that
yeah yeah that was some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] because just happened huh yeah I
mean it was like blacks and whites and
Mexicans will just like them everybody
and this is the crazy part Felipe's uh
you know the riots for real
dog when they come in and they turn off
all the TV the radios all communications
off because they think if we watch the
news and see the right it's going to
trigger another riot
another prison yeah it's like a [ __ ]
supposed to be planning those you turn
everything off cell phone yeah and then
that's what we knew something was up and
then the next day since that riot was by
us
it must have shipped over like 500 other
inmates and they made him sleep on the
lawn for two days fish they ship them
out of there or in the prison no it's
the prison next door to us is where I
went down so that prison was burned up
they burned half of it it wasn't
accessible for living Dan yeah dog it
was crazy it was like you thought 300
men was crazy being that [ __ ] [ __ ]
309 made out of Top Ramen or [ __ ]
magazines like fools look at their
magazine roll it up with sugar in their
[ __ ] hit you in the head
Hollister yeah I hit that full of sweet
spot ha ha
I give that boost our big day of being
I'm no medical I remember when I went
when I didn't show at Lompoc federal
penitentiary it was me and Gabriel
didn't show up for the guards and the
guy was telling me nah man he can't get
creative over here how creative Wow
we have one guy who got 5 ambos stole 5
hamburger no [ __ ] birthday balls and
no [ __ ] boy and now an F who wrapped
them up with saran wrap and made a dildo
bro now as our boss duck gay [ __ ]
himself talk about so much to make
himself good one of the ball other balls
came I had one stuck but he couldn't get
out so he was [ __ ] credit card god I
have a ball in me so what you're not
bothering you know this their money what
you know got stuck that's crazy guys UFO
had chunga ha ha
damn that's a hand ball for next and
what's it what got you in there fool
like was that an old case well what had
a buddy recognize you yeah what happened
was is a boy afraid of that yeah dog
it's like I didn't know that but I was a
gangster before this and I got into a
fight at the park for somebody it was
just the way I was I didn't talk back
then I didn't there was no podcast you
didn't have a debate
no back then if someone says something
not gonna [ __ ] out and it's called be in
your 20s go yeah exactly
so uh me and this full get down I [ __ ]
him up but you know doc I left the crime
scene I beat this full up once I seen he
could have moved on well you mention
that bro you left a crime scene people
forget that you're fighting in public
you're committing a crime yeah yeah man
and now man I left a lot of crime scenes
to I forgot that when you beat somebody
up and then you after the other floor
you keep pummeling them you know kicking
them in the head and peeing on them and
you walk away it's a life walked away
work crime scene I know you win for the
concerts listen man it was worth a
change stop the feds yeah [ __ ] that
nobody really stays yeah I had I thought
I was gonna get away with it like I
thought I would have got away with it if
it wasn't for comedy dog it also [ __ ]
I'm living life dog it's crazy like I'm
living life like it's already been a
year since this should happen I'm
[ __ ] stopped being a gangster I'm
dating some chick has taken me the
underground comedy like poet and she's
taking me the [ __ ] baby man hot dog
and I first you know I mean is it hey
man come on come on man I'm like no no
disrespect looking like I seen it in all
the a I can do this back and then uh
yeah dog [ __ ] so uh I get on MTV your
mama and I guess this [ __ ] see
me and and it sucks though because it's
I get busted as the seasons going down
like it's only like I've only been on
though I haven't even been on the best
of the best yet so I'm [ __ ] um I get
locked up dog a homie they lock me up
crazy I was DJing at California Gurls
there's a strip bar yeah I love that
place done yeah dog dog my [ __ ] count
went high because when all the strippers
seen the cops come kick the door down
and grab me they're like this
[ __ ] bad [ __ ]
dog but it was [ __ ] up because they
took me at 6:59 you get your tips at
6:30 so I was like [ __ ] I just lost 200
bucks it's Friday I'm not going to see a
judge till [ __ ] Monday so I go I get
locked up I see a judge and you know how
it is they're like you're like what's
this for and they're like oh you broke
this guy's eye socket [ __ ] pull all
this mother don't like I [ __ ] them up
and I just sat there like damn daughter
I thought I was going to be somebody and
then my brother to the rescue dog bailed
me out the same fool that build out
Michael Jackson Perez bail bonds yeah
because my brother smart he will look
right now they haven't gave you the
other charges your only charges assault
if they give you another charge is going
to make the bail go up so right now bail
was only 50 G's that foot pulled down 5
G's 10% boom I'm out doing MTV your mama
kick a dog hey I get bailed out on a
[ __ ] Wednesday night Orange County
Jail is 20 minutes away from El Patio
dog Edwin's hosting I [ __ ] walk in
there dogs I thought they'd seen a ghost
but I smelled like [ __ ] dog because I
was in the same clothes they lock me up
in and they all thought it was crazy I
remember trying to talk to girls and
they're like where'd you come from
I just got out the county [ __ ] into
five days but uh yeah dog that's that's
how I got locked okay and then uh I'm
out kick I'm kicking with you the whole
time you know I mean I'm fighting this
[ __ ] case
I'm partying I'm trying to live from
going up and don't we took over that bug
huh yeah yeah their exit bull yeah ah
[ __ ] I live in Oakland when I met Lisa
what I remember like he said hit me up
in an email
what's up what you doing you want to
blame a little [ __ ]
you got mail I got a little B mail and I
saw I saw you email and I didn't know
who it was that first you know probably
I made it too hot
yeah she's skinny a rich kid each it
should hold on to this one you know
anyway so yeah I meet Lisa and then we
go to the Casa latina fool everybody's
laughing in Georgia's there too that's
good I walked in holding her hand
such a rule yeah that subsidize that
room and you're said you're always loved
haha you're all sad hey when I said that
he squeezed her head tighter I told you
I would hold it show my muscles
nominally so the the show and um ah man
I don't know what's going I don't know
why I had told Joey you could spend a
night in my house already right I don't
know look overcome with with miss Lisa
Oh Daniel here the only white Sheila
never been to cover latina besides I'm
that girl from
volcana black-eyed peas are the
bartender bartender no back IP the real
black guy park at Fergie Fergie her mom
goes all the time oh yeah at the sunset
room that the Fergie's mom and then I
reserved a [ __ ] loaded this is not
way yeah you probably party with him bro
there's old man only or white lady and
um one time one time she gave him a
shout-out on TMZ I guess oh shut up to
my mom over there getting [ __ ] up in a
sense in the room so um yeah we walked
in to do the show and then I told people
to spend the night so I go home with
Lisa at my house do the dirty has stinky
ass speech she to get a [ __ ] I say you
know you're a friend somebody will be
with somebody forever
and to get pairing I leave my socks on
bro can't see looks bad told yet it's
not to another three years
we're going swimming have fun anyway doc
hey I suck with shoes on before done
just food Kluber will leave the floor
like a basketball player boss our
blackmart I'm Scott George we spoke with
shoes out here what happened I scored
triple double so I forgot that that's
we're going to spend the night so I'm in
there bro forget Lisa I know I know she
I don't know where she lives
spend the night it doesn't leave not lie
everybody here over breakfast asleep in
his bed everybody start now
no and then George is I looked outside
the burgers outside right post wagon
over there yeah what and I go in there
this was sleep in there bro like sign
for sleeping the Cadillac and a little
ass hat yeah cuz I'm full of when it
went um you know you know he was going
to look like everybody else who grew up
in the hood like when I have bald ass
head I started way hat or tiger in my
hair grow long so drug programs will
wear a little hat bro to drive so you'll
get pulled over right yeah I'm looking
like your co-host over yeah some people
bro and plus I knew I was gonna get
locked up so I was just living I know
that we wanted to live it up but I Henry
here before he leaves the hello to the
brothers we party hard you mean you're
hard I remember we went I remember like
we partied so hard one time I didn't
know you had a parking behind your
apartment I don't know how the [ __ ] I
ended up back there I'm gonna kill that
[ __ ] that day bro the landlord
yeah not in every word even doing
anything a your soul code that we were
scared to move we're so scariness by
knocking again hard are horrible we're
all coked out play Madden like Simon
hearing it ya know doing the radio
wasn't even armed bro yeah my paranoia I
said don't answer the door yeah
and that fool said a lot of noise put on
[ __ ] you get out of here their motto
cabron and then a counselor
actually yeah and I said while you could
take joy right away you know your boys
it's not right but they notice we were
chilled or was no man right notice me
there was no mess no no drugs yeah
there was no noise cuz he lived down to
yeah every [ __ ] snow buddy was
stopping okay i total colors and sir you
come inside you know if you want you
know search you know pretty much in
things in my life but there's like
something right yeah so no there's
nothing going on you're that guy just a
loser down there you seen is wild a
[ __ ] is arguing here to [ __ ] somebody's
nice and you know what also stuff at
your house dog is do you remember the
day
Kobe scored 83 we watch that [ __ ] at
your house yeah bro does me you and
Edwin and fly I think now is meeting you
and Edwin yeah me you and Edwin yeah cuz
fly didn't have five bucks for peak so
though no he did it
[Laughter]
that was the one day pulled out 500 were
you going for Newport are you a fool
we're going to a shore San Diego and we
[ __ ] we went by it by Edwards house
putting in gas and I food put it he
likes he puts it up just a little regal
at five and how far you going bro do you
port really down who the tightest we
work with Chapel or Oprah ah [ __ ] ah
Chapel God and Jeff and he PO I took
this for the Brawley dog drove um Fadem
game 200 bucks I come back I go a dog
let me get a coffee like alright let me
get a buck fifty I was like what the
[ __ ]
intercession to be to bro you're not the
only one does like I pushed them no like
I was mad I pushed on awesome what's
wrong with you dog Oh doctor say we did
I stop talking to that food so you want
to burn your coffee if you have a
business sense of the whole thing it's
[ __ ] loon I know you took my gauge
drove on $200 out I understand how you
give a guy like nobody does that like
pick you up you have to put no gas get
you a room give you $200 but you can't
give the guy a dollar fifty
Coffee yeah healer no business sense no
notic didn't and then you get angry
because you sort of discount in
actuality robbed me
for realz like he robbed me because I
don't like you take he won't tell me I
got a gig I got a gig and [ __ ] um in
San Jose how much he's gonna get 50
bucks
why bro I just get you again for $100 35
minutes on your house you gotta go over
there for fifty dollars for our Drive
bros that means that next time I book
you I should only give you two dollars
yeah that's the method the kind of man
you're doing to me right now
let me get a buck fifty he falls you
over to huh
you just [ __ ] on their [ __ ] just
tight as [ __ ] I won't let nothing slide
for Gaston yeah and but it I mean it
look at the way he's raised dog his
brothers a brother like they never gave
him toys they probably put them in a
safe in the cupboards and let me like
you you could tell like there's a family
when Apple came to welcome with the
black he showed up a Casa latina of the
black guy first
yeah when the brother yeah you to Bugsy
policy todo that you feel bad
did you try to help these people no
losing they go get it hey you remember
that time we're in the Icehouse parking
lot me you Edward in Chapel or blaze it
in Chiapas like my mom's on a honeymoon
right now in Mexico you're like yeah duh
right now she's wearing your dad's iris
in Jersey I forgot man yeah can I fool
it said Toby in mom has a robe on dizzy
bat her for she get that boyfriend out
them her boys with the sporting goods
store over here aim come dude or
something that yeah boy who she was in a
battle right Louis Leo's my first guest
on the podcast and um and every time we
mentioned his name he think we're
talking [ __ ] but I'm like you know
famous bro
oh man for real you don't talk to me
anymore he won't bro like every time we
mention his name he feels like we're
talking [ __ ] till we send people on his
to follow up on it we said a listener
what's that - he'll follow him and tell
him man I came here just to see you bro
and he was a y-y-ya god bro should have
got to follow from me nothing Filipe
yeah he gets mad fool yeah he's on that
like Emperor Tupac [ __ ] whatever yeah
Dawg like he's on a weird vibe the
lesson for nah man ain't no a sister
Tucker shut up I'm going hard two dogs
ID with Edward Tony goes dog I [ __ ]
took Chapel the Texas and the promoter
was my homie and his friend did a tattoo
for him for free oh is that what he got
that one on yeah
and yoga car and chemicals how much I
owe you and the guy goes hey Dodge just
you know show me a little love because
thanks doc I'll show you a lot of I'll
take care of it and everything like ed
was like not everyone gave the full 50
bucks yeah cuz I told that for you
didn't tip him don't ya even when you
pay for a tattoo you're supposed to do
whoa Wow a new level of cheapness a cha
damn San Fernando tip that's his
cheating card roll hey bro you have a
[ __ ] joke on your sleeve that a right
here bro yeah there are Jokers right all
right yeah what I've been embarrassed
about
Edwin bro uh I think [ __ ] it that's
like Darth Carrington right there bet me
bro that's like um don't let him saying
that yeah I'm a hop all day and then the
meal shows up but you don't really help
out his helping out a putting the dishes
away but there's a little scoop member
so I watch your arm i watch the things
he's doing man you and I'm you're on our
[ __ ] um Comedy Store a lot you're on
[ __ ] or death squad shows you know
and that's awesome bro I'm glad that
you're staying away from all those other
losers bro oh [ __ ] yeah I don't know
[ __ ] about the 101 north you know you're
talking about Zach every Latino comedian
out there who doesn't go past the 101
it like they think that everything is
happening pastor 6:05 it doesn't act
like I understand why like I noticed
that when I stopped started going to
comments towards a young comedian a lot
of different opportunities opening up
yeah
so you looking to get - I'll put two
little Doodlebops you now more committee
don't follow the same thing you're doing
I mean a dog they don't have the mental
toughness it's like these guys I've been
in the game longer than a lot of these
other fools and like not let you win for
being a big fish in a big in a small
pool - being a small fish yeah no food
don't know how to humble ourselves yeah
I want to be the man and every throw up
and it's [ __ ] door fits well for Oh
bleep you know like these guys honey I
gotta give you five for the there's no
most of the easy rooms you were so sure
to rule that our pact getting scheduled
guests but I heard it sold out yeah how
about that guest but when I want to
bring you over those ten people you're
too scared to go up yeah yeah I mean if
what they're doing now is it's a new
hustle that I Oh squeaky clean comedy
for your high school or [ __ ]
fundraisers and a fundraiser that's a
new scam bro yeah and it's just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] no bro
oh yeah it's a fundraiser for lung
cancer yeah bro how much they pay for
you I don't let's not talk about that
yeah so yeah I mean a dog like when I
first went there it was weird like how
you said being humbled by nobody [ __ ]
knows you really buddy man nobody nobody
big huge oh dear yeah I mean I knew
totally ages and dug but this was
craziest when I first got out of prison
Wilma Guetta MTV your mama it's like I
don't know why he hasn't released it but
it was like March Madness there was
sixty-four battlers and acting I'm aid
it to the end dawg guess who [ __ ] I
went up against who Tony Hinchcliffe god
oh man and he was just a door guy back
there yeah he was starving dog like it
was weird because like I thought I was
going to murder this guy he looked like
one of those kids that Greek used to
molest back in the old days you know
what I mean and the food with a squire
haha
I saw a dog me in this full battle I
feel like Cyberdyne evades me in this
full battle for like 40 minutes dog
back-to-back head-to-head and I lost out
he hit me with a good one I was running
a cream sweater and he goes damn I know
you guys like her chopped I don't know
you guys worried and you know when a
white black people hear that [ __ ]
they're like ah [ __ ] this beer and they
got me dog and I shut up to the Comedy
Store like about five years later and
he's somebody there now equals come here
dog I know who you are and he showed me
love red been shown me love Joey did
show me love and then you know how it is
you got to go on stage over there and
follow somebody big or somebody sorry
whoever but it's all up for grabs and I
was like [ __ ] it I just went up I show
up every day early with all the open
mike is giving tomorrow hot look yeah I
was looking for the number in a bowl
yeah I homie I did everything and that's
old-school later huh and I mean I'm not
but you know hungry as unknown zoiwako
gonna wake up and in your room sod yeah
but then Yorkshire pot how could they
are like a year later yeah like what the
[ __ ] this one really cares you see the
other four that are just there for
[ __ ] and [ __ ] but I don't know you
know the rest not going up on the side
over yeah it's enough for one season
they need to release that DVD all the
Montreal the salty party bro that I tell
it to you are you might not be allowed
to go to Montreal I know
no I already can't even fly huh I mean
actually get in George now we're all
supposed to be there this week yeah
which this week I had a show really bro
lined up bro I want to let you win 1990
I was arrested for an ounce and a half
of crack but I wasn't even mind I got
bailed out the same day I got a DEA
reject but I guessed
no evidence district attorney reject you
know I showed up to court you know ready
for a sad story have my kids their baby
photos everything that's great
oh and tell you how we do it your old
coach Oh coach father Boyle first of all
the boy was there bro [ __ ] yo Santo
with a candle burning for me and the the
clerk told me da reject so I figure that
was it so I left so and then when I go
to try to go to Canada it always shows
up it always shows up then then I got a
sitter for two hours so dead time you
know we went through all that state and
led the FBI clearance the change would
be so Wow
Canada changed it and made a hardcore
because I'm here in America they made a
hardcore for everybody else so Canada
getting back at us
yeah yeah if you're another US passport
oh yeah I mean I'm scared to even try to
go down oh yeah shows me you're scared
too bro I'm almost scared right now cuz
I'll find something
so then they offered me the the main
main guy for the Montreal festival he
wanted me on a show he said listen man I
could make a phone call to the Customs
Service in Canada but that she's gonna
cost $3500 it's a wild man that's not a
[ __ ] phone call I don't have to be
holy [ __ ] I maybe get paid that much man
no just forget about it man would you
deal with it next year yeah [ __ ] any
more time you know what the best thing
you can do is try me trying to get it
sponge that's what I heard
I'm gonna go get my record sponge you
just kind of find a girl you could do it
bro I could do it ya know because I got
two strikes and a half right no I only
got one strike because it's it's it's
the other strike strike itself out I got
a great bodily injury
okay listen taco boy you go to the
prisoner hit no no can't worry about the
Bears Jason Bourne over here ripping off
Chris records over here for the solo
Secret Service here hell yeah but for
the CIA
oh no Connie its outside investigator
get the Kingsmen over here yeah no I
mean like I've looked into it uh Tommy
brown over yeah because hey Doc Gucci
man gets the Canada Gucci man just got
out of prison wrist Chris Brian no Chris
Parrillo showed up with poor sports
their minds
full of concert equipment merge another
another fire bomb rental van full of a
[ __ ] entourage and he was in the
front
they said nah man you be the Rihanna
yeah for sold-out arenas but $1,000,000
worth of work or more Boomhauer to shut
up a Michael Buble and Russell Peters
daughter ballet let me if you're on a
plane
don't let you in bro yeah yeah not to
the door because there when I was when I
flew into Canada with Russell Peters
they just sick my idea came in my chest
down by private jet Stavros Spencer and
then we we flew back bro we made a stop
in [ __ ] Spokane Washington they check
their IDs bro I ain't never recognize me
by the way are you from that's coming
here and then I Rosa were like hey it's
my plane yeah I hate private planes bro
and you hate Harry
it comes in all my every time I'm in
those I take a [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
bathroom full of luggage bro were some
fool with you or do Toyota Park hell
yeah man
and for Perez torn apart I'm glad you
started a podcast bro thanks I'm didn't
even ask anybody a short audio podcast
because some people whenever somebody
ask me should I start a podcast at say
for if you're asking me you can start
work yeah cuz I'm not again who say yes
or no to podcast how did you Tony how do
you come up with I'm your homeboy hey
what's your name that's like save your
wallet like the first havior and gotta
get with a beard at site dick eddie
sidekick and yeah sided caddy I mean it
all started with I did Rogen's podcast
and then like I've got so many people
turn a doubt what what the [ __ ] where I
can I hear more of you know that you
know what man it's time to get off your
[ __ ] ass and you got fools like you
and like all these bigger fools and us
are doing this [ __ ] every day like I
said it's time for me to play with the
big boys now I just jumped in dog house
I'm gonna do stories [ __ ] it and it's
[ __ ] fun I love it it's like a stress
relief huh
it's a party zone bro yeah I wanna party
I've got a man electric podcast to our
pocket to go straight the full state
breaks that 0:25 a testicle break at 12
under five minutes movie
lovely words from our sponsors this poor
lives and elect in leg dog and in the I
don't know what's the delivered Cyprus
in Cyprus but isn't he living a part of
Cyprus borough where it's trying to it's
trying to stay clean but it's still
keeping the Cyprus tradition Brooke yeah
it's like it's a middle-class
neighborhood with rednecks and masculine
bro yeah and I knew it was a trailer
trash neighborhood bro when I showed up
and there's a [ __ ] above-ground pool
my next-door a furthest out boys in his
yard down at the back in and the front
of the jumping people are diving from
the porch now man gets away yeah bro his
[ __ ] house to smother fireworks yeah
man I loved you on the podcast all you
[ __ ] a man like not to hate on other
guests but like I went back because I'm
a we reminisced about shade of a swan
dog I know man some people don't
understand that we do a podcast opposed
to just be honest be yourself
yeah so we will come in like wow you
don't want a first our guest on a car
with the monocle are you should take me
to Australia I thought it was you're
done
we are Martin Mourinho here bro as a
solid I haven't seen him in yes who went
to up north to learn how to be a [ __ ]
a guru bro Ricky priest Oh Ricky priest
Ricky [ __ ] area how you learn to be a
guru I take a test or something right
get a certificate to a ceremony that
will get him across his legs in this
time he cared dog he just wears the
pants I was painted snafu is um that
fools out there doing it bro like he had
either I don't know man [ __ ] just
shall join what Ricky Dicky is bro I
don't even know what I want to remember
theme what Ricky Dicky energy in change
Martine does much it does energy seek or
energy from you bro like some people use
a egg this food go that dislike this but
stones and like magnet to channel or
your body yeah telephoto take my
psoriasis off my [ __ ]
Alma's in love so atmosphere out there
yeah Joe's coming up um dan I think I
just I I don't know that I'm [ __ ]
high what I have coming up when do the
next time George stories podcast uh I'm
gonna start doing two a week now so I
think I'm gonna drop on Friday I'm gonna
do it Thursday night who guessed this
last week uh it was Yoshi Yoshi Yoshi
Yoshi no yeah it was crazy that guy that
used to like give me points to go by
thing and we called it the naked truth I
we did was talk about porn and
prostitution and brothels and not like
it was it was pretty [ __ ] crazy
she's crazy huh yeah this fault I never
knew I guess there's this famous porn
star chick that like she was like I've
done everything so she told her her
[ __ ] her Rodrigo go give me a
homeless dude she got this homeless
won't start a [ __ ] sucking him off
until he was having a seizure dog and
they're like stop it she's like no I'm
trying to kill him because what I did
wash his big first know exactly none of
that I've been around my dig three days
without washing boy he's tugging at
[ __ ] cheese in there bro and I could
just imagine a homeless guy man and I'm
gonna fold I should put a condom at
least
now dog she was with it that's all wrong
washes food how much will ya for free
you know what bro you know you were
[ __ ] to go to heaven bro yeah no I
don't need to go to heaven yeah because
I was hell with the room now that man
had somewhere to stay but uh but yo she
told me that uh wow that guy telling him
the story was like the old man was
[ __ ] fighting back to stay alive
looking at her because she they said
that he was just having like he was
tripping out has it got a dick sucking
decade huh by a beautiful porn star Wow
I would have came in 32nd stop that
homeless guy he probably feels like that
every time he smells crack flashbacks
imagine the stories he has and he goes
back well you've been you did you hang
out the comedy story tell me your party
with Johnny Depp huh after the show
littering with our celebrities and we
want to hang out huh yeah
mean yeah dog it's like you get to meet
so terribly returnees there huh yeah dog
and John Mayer totally Johnny Depp is
like as five said not five eight five
nine one minute movies going to talk
yeah John Mayer was there it's alright
yeah he's cool he loves rows battle you
know they do that rose bottle at the
Comedy Store every Tuesday night plugin
for you [ __ ] but I yeah uh Brian
Moses
yeah Brian Moses Maimonides colors hell
yeah and Jeff Ross do they got me on
that [ __ ] I hope tough it was a trip dog
right Moses I met him at the at the San
Diego Comedy Store okay we're working
the door and I walked in the door guess
it and I was looking for weed - I said
hello there and I saw him man and that
fool sold me our [ __ ] sack sack two
sacks but I only have enough money for
one I think fool he said just take it
you to me later Barney we're gonna see
you again
school I don't know how many years went
by the one that's coming standing then I
had a shorter communist or I see I'm all
[ __ ] hey man I owe you money and I give
the money right there
I saw sob dog yeah I know like what I
give him the money right there I post
chapo bro is I don't know you
yeah hey someone introduce it forget
about it yeah I never smoke the weed
here I'm on [ __ ] another user fool I
remember when Edwin Winona he went on up
and did a great tour somewhere Edwards
on one and I took the bus to meet chapo
and him and I took the bus to me
Illinois house cuz he was coming from
San Diego so we were waiting for his ass
and that fool went to Dillon's and he
gave me a 8th and he gave Chapel AIDS
and he gave
Lloyd Christmas I ate and then when
after Edwin left
I said [ __ ] I open up my little
aids and I said where everybody pull or
dug in here yeah detector shoulder hey
hot dog ever had what I mean Lloyd
Christmas put a half a gram in my nose
yeah I made shampoo put in another grab
the chapel there posted tea egg that was
low
Christmas first Asia you ever had and
you took a dug up well the first answer
you ever had dogs and they we're gonna
have an 18 ugh it's our tackles food dog
[ __ ] that so half on a gram
how has Chapel still been around like
crazy
I don't know Brooke we keep mentioning
that hopefully bewilder survive yeah man
we're so full podcast Yemen shout out to
everybody we listening right now man
we're gone for two weeks we're gonna
play catch-up alright yeah man our new
shirt coming out which one have to
ensure one of the new t-shirts look like
a massive pile and has my name on it and
the other one the other one is that
Aztec calendar with my face on it man
it's pretty wild and awesome we're gonna
be signing on for $30 now okay man we'll
drop the price I heard people
complaining already and 25 bucks also
the album the album the what's a full
album September 30 HBO this week August
5th when you're watching George Lopez
live a little commercial Felipe Esparza
follow me right now right now yeah okay
and we're going to release 500 copies
just on vinyl on records sake
commemoratives they're all going to be
signed there's going to be prizes inside
and downloadable it will be an awesome
album so be sure to get that it's a
little bit for 50 bucks and we'll have
the digital release also all this will
be after November 30 so that what they
told us
okay well let me get a pre-order down so
I can put it on my podcast all dark we
were dealing about that but the reason
is that you are sure to put up he's like
I'll get da slow down we don't have time
ma'am but I wasn't [ __ ] Des Moines
Iowa bro goddamn what happened goddamn
bro I'll get back to talk about this
next time but god damn bro you got my
money goodbye
I saw 32 round clip just right there bro
you just grab it grab it bro huh well
it's lollipops
is there cholos other [ __ ]
knocking five border brothers by Rivals
and I just asked the other driver
license yes we do
I'll be right back with a paperwork
let's say like five bikes I was buying
done bro
[ __ ] that do you know firefighters gonna
buy no [ __ ] guns it's kinda Anibal
whatever you actually was going is the
Des Moines so the okapi South Vietnamese
are arming themselves in Bethesda bro
and I'm sorry to say been Santa but the
whole [ __ ] City of Des Moines Iowa
are arming themselves bro here in
California were arguing about soy food
what so food dude